[Music]
everybody as they say the best goes last
and here we are to talk about testing
Android apps at scale my name is Stefan
insula and I'm a software engineer at
Google and with me backstage is Vishal
Satya who's also a software engineer at
Google said Google we believe in
diversity and inclusion and we build our
products for everyone but for us
developers this means we also have to
test for everyone so let me tell you a
little bit how we develop and test
software at Google but before I start I
want to talk a little bit about the
scale that we do Android development
here at Google we have about a hundred
plus Android apps this includes all the
billion user apps Shutts such as Google
photos maps YouTube Gmail search we have
a combined two billion lines of code and
we run twenty thousand Android builds
every single day and we have a
staggering 27 million test invocations
per day so how do we create these high
quality apps and how do we maintain this
quality over such a long time I think
one of the key things here is our
engineering culture a typical developer
workflow at Google looks a little bit
like this we have a strong code review
in cultured code you use are very very
thorough and before you can actually
submit your change or pull requests you
have to get at least reviewed by one of
your peers another important thing is
that all development happens at hat and
everything is built from source and we
have a large mono repo which allows us
to easily search for code reuse code but
it also allows us to keep the repo
healthy by sending SUSE called
large-scale changes we also have a very
strong testing culture
at Google if you have a change you have
to have tests and even more importantly
all of those tests have to pass before
you submit your change to run tests we
use a large-scale distributed CI system
which does not only run your tests but
also all of the tests from code that
depends on your change another thing
that is very unique about Google is that
we have a strong engineering
productivity culture so that means we
have dedicated teams that only work on
infrastructure tools and api's to make
developers productive we are part of
such a team and we've been working on
testing Android apps or Android app
testing at Google so I want to take you
a walk down memory lane what we have
done at Google to scale Android testing
so in about 2011 a lot of teams at
Google actually started to build for
Android because Android was becoming
more and more popular so at the time
they were just using the standard tool
chain they were using ant to build their
apps and they were using Eclipse as an
editor but with a growing number of
teams we also added support to our
internal build system one of the
problems that became obvious very early
on was the need for scalable testing and
so we actually started off very simple
by building a small ho sight test runner
that would run on the host and in fact
it was just a J unit 3 test suite they
would literally scan an apk list the
tests and give it to our instrumentation
test runner that was running on the
device to execute the test once we had
that we actually build it into our
continuous integration system one of the
key decisions that we made very early on
was to use emulators we call them
virtual devices to run tests at scale
because obviously it makes more sense
because you can scale a data center but
you can probably not scale I use be
happy so easily
so we wrote this little Python script
probably just 20 lines of code and I'm
sure many of you have been there that
boots up an emulator for us that allows
us to run the tests and shut it down
afterwards so while we were working on
infrastructure our engineers actually
started started to write tests and he
wrote a lot of them a key problem here
was especially around functional UI
testing and as many of you will remember
in the early days you only had the
low-level framework api's we had
activity monitor to track activities you
had instrumentation run on UI thread or
the infamous wait until idle sync and
even though these methods these api's
were were easy to use developer
struggled a lot
writing the reliable UI tests and at the
time we thought okay maybe we could find
something better and we actually found
that in a community with Robottom so we
brought Robottom into google and it
improved things and we used it for about
a year until the end of 2012 but it had
its own issues with the API surface and
it didn't solve one of our key issues
which was synchronization and that's
when we started to work on espresso
because we wanted a framework that was
easy to use for developers but more
importantly was hiding all the
complexity of instrumentation testing
from the developer so at that point we
kind of had a decent set up for
instrumentation tests but we still had
to solve the unit testing problem
because as you remember at the time all
of your unit tests you usually ran them
on the device but that is expensive and
they tend to be slower than running
under JVM so again we reached for a
solution that the community had already
built at the time which was robolectric
and robolectric allowed our developers
to do fast iterative local development
and it's actually still one of the most
popular frameworks for unit testing
within Google so in 2014 we actually had
built a lot of experience in testing
api's but we were seeing
that the community was struggling you
know from the same problems that we did
that's why we decided to bundle all of
our libraries together in the Android
testing support library which then
quickly became the default library for
developers to write instrumentation
tests fast forward to today we just
launched Android X test one at zero it's
not only our first stable release it's
also the first time where we ship
unified api's that allow you to write
tests once and run them anywhere and by
the way we just achieved a major
milestone here at Google we now run 10
billion unit and instrumentation tests
every year on our infrastructure so
looking back at those seven years what
would we do differently there's a couple
of things I want to mention here so we
would probably design for any build
system we made some key decisions very
early on that tightly coupled us to
Google's internal build system but it
quickly became a problem because even at
Google not everybody's using Google's
internal build system and we weren't
able to share our builds our hosted
infrastructure with them but also not
with the community and we couldn't
open-source it similarly we didn't build
some of the tools that we've built
weren't cross-platform so they only
worked on Linux but not Mac and Windows
another thing that we would probably do
differently even though retrospectively
it probably was a good thing that we
started off small and then scaled up our
testing but while the apps grew and the
ecosystem grew there were more and more
requirements and we usually just built
them into our infrastructure but we
didn't have a mechanism for teams to
customize this infrastructure it's led
to a point where we suffered from high
code complexity it was hard to maintain
and some features couldn't be removed
but they weren't used anymore
the last thing I wanna mention is
configuration our hosted infrastructure
was getting configuration from many
different sources so we had Flags system
environment variables in config files
and his
very hard to track down box in the
infrastructure itself so about a year
ago our team sat down with app teams in
Google and we wanted to learn about
about the past and the future and
especially how the Android testing
landscape had changed and so what we
came up with to solve some of the
problems that came out of the discussion
was project nitrogen project nitrogen is
our new unified testing platform which
we first talked about at i/o this year
and which will ship to you in 2019
project nitrogen is currently used by a
small number of apps inside of Google
and we're slowly scaling it up to some
of the biggest apps in the world and the
reason why we're doing this is simply
because we want to battle test it first
before we ship it to you but the point
being here is we want to give all this
infrastructure that we use to run ten
billion tests to you so nitrogen solves
many problems but two of the key issues
that we're trying to solve with nitrogen
is first we want to create a unified
entry point into Android development and
secondly we want you to n able to write
tests with the unified API and move them
between layers if you think about
Android testing today it looks a little
bit like this right you have tools on
the left-hand side such as Android
studio Gradle you have your CI server
and maybe even another build system such
as basil on the other end of the
spectrum you have all the different
runtimes that you want to run on we call
runtime device devices in nitrogen so
you want to run your tests on a
simulated device or a virtual or
physical device or even on a remote
device that runs in a device labs such
as firebase test lab but in order to do
so you have many different entry points
and it looks a little bit like this you
have a different configuration for every
tool you have different roles you have
different tasks and it just becomes a
nightmare to maintain and
actually what we see in Google is
because it's so hard to move from one to
the other they would school towards one
type of a test or another so what we
want to do with nitrogen is we want to
have a unified entry point and nitrogen
itself is just a standalone binary a
standalone tool which infrastructure
developers can use to really customize
their infrastructure but obviously
there's also all these auto developers
who don't work on infrastructure and
work on actual lab code for them we want
to provide integrations into all the
tools on the left-hand side to make it
easy to run tests and at that point if
you have a single entry point and a
unified test it fits very well within
your developer workflow because you can
do local fast iterative development on a
simulated device then in pre submit
before you actually submit your change
you can run on an emulator matrix and
lastly in post submit you can run on a
remote device a physical device in
firebase test lab and that's really what
we're trying to do with
nitrogen-nitrogen
allows you to run tests at scale it is
highly configurable it was built with
customization and extensibility in mind
you can execute unit and instrumentation
tests it vastly improves reporting and
therefore debugging and maybe one of the
most exciting things as it ships with
its own virtual device management
solution that manages devices for you
and that's actually something I think a
lot of people in the community I've been
asking for us for quite a while so
nitrogen is cross-platform and we really
build it from the ground up with all the
experience that we have seven years in
ho site and device that infrastructure
it will support Mac Windows and Linux
and is written in Kaplan and we really
build it in a way such that we hopefully
that
hopefully going to be good for the next
seven years nitrogen as I was saying
it's just a standalone tool so it can be
easily integrated into any build system
and we're working on integrations for
Gradle basal and basal we're adding
sharding and parallel test execution and
continuous integration support will be
there from the start on the device side
we're initially planning to have support
for at least simulated virtual and
physical devices as well as device labs
such as firebase test lab and you can
even add your custom devices if you have
custom hardware so let's switch gears a
little bit and talk a little bit about
the high-level architecture of nitrogen
so nitrogen is basically split into two
parts we have a host side infrastructure
that is all the coasts all the code that
runs on a host and we've done something
new we also have an on device
infrastructure which basically means
we've moved some of our infrastructure
on third on to the device which is a
much saner environment to reason about
and the device is also the main
abstraction that we use in nitrogen for
different runtimes so the host side
runner is mostly responsible for finding
a device for you setting up the device
for test execution and then requesting a
test run it can be easily configured
with a proto buffer configuration and it
allows you to customize things like the
test executor and the whole test harness
to decouple the host from the device we
have a new Orchestrator service you can
think of it as the brain of test
execution that runs on a device and it's
responsible for discovery filtering and
sorting and execution
an Orchestrator service is just a G RPC
service that can be implemented by any
device and we in fact use G RPC to
communicate between the host and the
device which does not give us
performance and speed it also gives us a
lot of stability and it allows us to
stream test results back to the host in
real time we also have a lot of
extension points so we'll have host
plugins that allow you to run code on a
host and we'll also have device plugins
that allow you to run code on a device
so let's dive into each of these
sections as I mentioned before we use a
single protocol figuration with a
declarative set of proto's this allows
you to define devices your test fixtures
so you can define things like apks that
you want to install data dependencies
that you want to push on the device and
it can declare your host and device
plug-ins we initially will have support
for single device executors parallel
device executors to run on multiple
devices in parallel and we'll also have
a new multi device executor which will
allow you to do things like
orchestrating a test run between a
device and a device or a device and a
watch which is something that we
increasingly see as a requirement the
good news is if you're just an app
developer you usually don't have to deal
with any of this configuration because
it's built in in the tool integration
but if you're an infrastructure
developer this is where it gets really
interesting for you because you can
customize every single bit of nitrogen
let's talk a little bit about plugins so
host plugins are plugins they can
execute code on a host plugins that
we've already built our the android
plug-in they just encapsulate all the
code that allows us to run Android tests
on a device
we have a data plugin that allows us to
stage data on to the device or a fixer
script plug-in which allows us to
execute fixer scripts on a device and
you can have your custom plugins custom
plugins can have their own configuration
and with host plugins you can actually
run before the test suite start and
after the test with is finish the reason
why we do it this way is because we want
to avoid the chattiness between the host
and the device if you look at the after
all method you will also get access to
the whole test suite result which is
great if you want to do any
post-processing of your test results and
you even can submit an edit request back
to us if you want to attach new
artifacts to the test suite result
device plugins on the other hand like
the name is saying Vani are running on
an actual device which is a much more
sane environment to reason about and in
fact most of our host site code that we
used to configure the device is now
moved to the device with a device plugin
so plugins that we've already built our
a Lochhead plugin that gives you a
scoped lock hat per test method a screen
shot plugin that takes screenshots in
case your tests fail or a permission
plug-in was pretty awesome because you
can now grant and revoke runtime
permissions which was not able before
and you can obviously also have your
custom plugins so the difference from a
device plug into a host plug-in is that
it runs on a device but this allows us
to do things like that we can give you a
call back before a single test method is
executed and after it's finished and
this is great because we can avoid all
the chattiness between a host and the
device and it gives you a lot of control
and if you think about it I don't know
how you set up your test fixtures now
but usually you would basically use
something like epi for class or at
before at after at after class or if you
want something more reusable you would
probably reach for a Jaina troll or
there's some things you can't do with
these api's and then you have to have
your custom runner and I think the great
thing about this is we give you a whole
new way of writing plugins that actually
run on a device and allow you to execute
code on it so let's move on to execution
so as I was saying we moved the
execution to the actual device and we
created a whole new Orchestrator service
and protocol what this does it
standardizes the communication between
the host and the device and it can be
implemented by any device which means if
you have a custom device you can
implement the same protocol and you can
still integrate with the house side
easily on Android the orchestrator
service is implemented by the Android
test Orchestrator and once you request
the test run on the host it will then go
discover all the tests apply any filters
and sorting that you want and then it
will do either isolated or batched test
execution it will also call all your
device plug-ins and it will stream
results back in real time to the hosts
so the last thing that I want to talk
about is reporting so when nitrogen we
will give you unified inconsistent
reporting as I'm sure many of you have
seen this command at the top what it
does is it runs an instrumentation test
from the command line if you use the -
our option which is where both mode
you will get an output like this as you
can see it's not very human readable I
would say and it's also quite chatty
because this is just showing a single
test and this is showing a passing test
if it fails the only thing that it gives
you an addition is a stack trace so
there's not really a lot of information
or actionable data here to why that has
failed with nitrogen we want to we want
to move to something like this a
structured data format which gives you
access to the properties of the test
case the status of the test and a list
of artifacts that were collected during
a test run things like screenshots video
locket and any custom artifacts that you
add in your post-processing again this
will also be integrated in Android
studio and we will surface this in the
Android studio UI if you run tests the
last thing before I wrap up what I want
to mention is we also have support for
custom reports so you can do things like
Jane at XML or even your custom report
that integrates better with your own
infrastructure and with that I want to
hand over to the shell who is going to
talk about device management all right
thanks to fun
running any kind of Android UI test
generally happens in devices there are
two different device types where you
could run your test either on a physical
device or a virtual device regardless of
which device type you run your test on
it each of them has its own sets of pros
and cons let's just do a quick show of
hands how many people around here have
had setup something like this you know
testing on physical devices looks like
part of you the follow-up question how
easy was it to manage them hard yeah
another follow-up question did you ever
end up using a fire extinguisher next to
it seriously hope not I have a funny
story to share that happened a few years
ago at Google when one of the teams
decided that they wanted to test their
stuff on physical devices they procured
a bunch of devices load them onto the
wall and and integrated with their CI
infrastructure everything was running
reasonably well until one fine day when
the engineers came back to work on a
Monday morning and things were timing
out if you were to guess what went wrong
what would be your guess look like okay
so turned out to be an air conditioner
problem so what apparently happened was
the air conditioners in building in San
Francisco went bad and because the air
conditioners went bad the facilities
decided that they want to switch off the
air conditioner so that they could fix
it but tests were continuously running
on those devices and the heat produced
in those devices caused the glue to peel
off from them from the wall and all the
devices fell off to the ground
managing physical devices are hard you
just want to give out a huge shout-out
to the firebase test lab team that makes
testing on firebase test lab so much
easier for you folks how do we solve
this at Google at Google we use the
virtual device infrastructure the test
environment that we use is extremely
stable the number that you look at the
right is distributed ratio of our test
environment and that's right it's
99.9999% the continuous integration in
the virtual device infrastructure that
we use has the ability to run locally or
in a CI environment and it supports over
500 different device configurations
let's dig in a little deeper to see what
its current state at Google it's used by
over 100 first party apps such as Google
Photos search YouTube and so on and so
forth just in 2018 it had a staggering
2.4 billion invitations and that number
is growing year-over-year
there are over 120,000 targets that use
this infrastructure having a great test
infrastructure is a must if you want to
release high quality apps you'd be
thinking this is great infrastructure
how does this fit in with nitrogen if
you remember from slides that Stefan
presented a little bit earlier nitrogen
has this concept of device providers so
if you want to run a UI test you invoke
nitrogen nitrogen in turn would invoke a
device provider which in this case it's
going to be the virtual device provider
which launches the device does a bunch
of smart setup returns the control back
to nitrogen which Act which actually
goes and executes the test and once the
test is done it goes and tears down the
device so in that case you get a
completely stable environment which
which is launched by nitrogen runs the
test and shuts it down so while
designing this particular infrastructure
there were four key things that we kept
in mind that the virtual device
infrastructure needs to be simple to use
needs to be extremely stable you should
be it should be reproducible regardless
of which environment it runs in whether
you're running it locally or whether
you're running it in your CI
infrastructure and it needs to be
extremely fast let's dig into a little
deeper as to how did we achieve each of
these four goals in building a virtual
device management solution so the what
the virtual device infrastructure has a
very simple protocol figuration what
does that mean it's just a configuration
file where you could go and add the
characteristics of the device for
example what's the horizontal screen
resolution what's the vertical screen
resolution what's the memory of the
device so for each of these different
device types like Nexus and pixel the
virtual device management solution
already has pre-baked in all of these
different device configurations so you
don't have to go and figure out the
different device resolutions for each of
those devices it supports over 500
different device configurations and
because it's a configuration file it's
matter of just adding or removing the
changes to the configuration file and it
supports several different form factors
such as phones tablets TV devices and
very devices but how is it simple
launching it is as simple as calling the
virtual device binary and specifying the
name of the device if you want to launch
a pixel tool you just say virtual device
device equals pixel to and on what API
level you don't have to worry about
creating a V de specifying
configurations and things like that
that makes things extremely simple
stability this is probably one of the
biggest problems most of the Android app
developers face like running your tests
and ANR pops up and that ANR might not
even necessarily be the app that you are
testing we had the same problem
internally as well how did we solve this
well sorry I know it has a nifty service
called as activity controller that lets
you suppress ANR's whenever it sees them
this is the exact same service that
Android monkey uses violet runs monkey
tests this increased our stability of
our tests tremendously like one of the
things that I forgot to say when we
started with this particular
infrastructure our stability was around
95% but that's no good when you're
running things at scale so the first
thing that we saw were ANR's
and once we fixed that our stability
increased but still not to the level
that we wanted the next flaky things
that we saw was the boot up a device but
the screen is not unlocked and if the
screen is not unlocked all the key
events that you inject does not even
reach your app and if the key events
don't reach your app your app is
actually not getting tested and yet has
starting to fail and it turned out when
the device boots up the screen is not
locked so in screen is not unlocked in a
free level 23 I believe Android added an
API from for our window manager where
you could dismiss the key guard and that
would unlock the screen so every time he
booted the device we would call the
window manager API to unlock the screen
and this increase trust ability
furthermore a few years ago Android
changed the file system from yaffs2
another flash file system to ext4
this was a great improvement but it had
its own set of problems ext4 was known
was prone to disruption during a hard
shutdown so whenever we would shut down
the device if it was not correctly shut
down and it had disk errors your
subsequent boot of the virtual device
would fail leading to test flakiness how
did we solve this problem well all we
had to do was call in F sake to the disk
image that was unmounted and this kind
of guaranteed that when the disk was
unmounted it had no disk errors and if
there were no disk errors your
subsequent boot would come up just fine
this increased the stability of our test
environment to close to 99% but that's
still no good when you're running at 2.4
billion invitations of one person
failure is 24 million that's still a
huge number as you can see there were a
bunch of optimizations that we did to
increase the stability I'm not going to
talk about all of them but there's one
final thing that I want to talk about we
would launch the device but for and the
virtual device would set a boot properly
saying that the device is completely
booted up but for whatever reasons the
launcher would not kick in now so how
did we solve that problem well all we
had to do was send out an intent to the
launcher if it was already launched then
was a no op if it wasn't launched then
it started the launcher and then we
would return the control back to
nitrogen which would then go and run the
test doing a bunch of optimizations like
this help us get to 99.9999% stability
the next big pillar the next big pillar
that we had in mind was reproducibility
a lot of times when users were running
their tests in CI environment if their
tests failed for whatever reasons they
had no way of debugging it locally so
are the virtual device environment that
we built had to make sure that the
environment was reproducible regardless
of where they are running so the virtual
device management solution helps you
launch things locally or on the cloud
and one of the big the big things about
this environment is the device starts in
a clean pristine State for every
invocation so there is no state carry
forward between different and vacations
making sure like tests are going to be
extremely stable and not failed because
of the device itself
a nutshell there are several teams
within Google that write NDK code like
when you're writing native code and they
wanted to test their native code but to
test a native code they wanted to boot
up arm devices and booting up arm
devices were extremely slow for example
on Mugen booting up an arm device takes
about 10 minutes and this was slowing
things down tremendously this helped
this made us go back to the drawing
board to see what could we do to
increase the to decrease the time it
takes to boot up those devices so we
ended up going and created a mini boot
mode in the virtual device
what does mini boot mode mean we like
for testing native code you don't need
the entire Android stack to be up and
running all you need is technically the
Linux kernel and if the kernel is up and
running you could test your native API
so we ended up and we ended up adding a
mini boot mode to our virtual device
launcher which would come up in less
than 30 seconds and that would help the
the NDK developers to tested in native
code much more quickly by Google we make
a lot of data-driven decisions so
because we were running things at scale
we were looking very very spending bulk
of our time while running our tests and
turned out 50% of our time was spent in
booting up the emulator 30% of the time
was spent in installing an app because
of a process called list x2o
and 20% of the time was spent in running
the test itself Android made a change
with between lollipop and a new Girt
where they wanted to do ahead of time
compilation using a tool called is text
to old and so what we so because the app
installation times were so huge what we
ended up doing was you have the exact
same device the exact same app under
test that's being tested and the exact
same next to old file that the exact
same old file being generated for every
test invocation what we said was what if
we move this as a single action as a on
a on the basal Bell graph and reuse the
old file that was generated for all your
test runs this significantly reduced the
app install time from over three minutes
for one of the apps to under a minute
if you were here earlier today when the
emulator team presented about snapshots
where you could boot up an emulator
safety snapshot and then shut down the
emulator and when you restart it it
restarts back from the same state valve
we integrated the snapshot feature back
into virtual device launcher
where you boot up a device take a
snapshot shut it down and then reuse it
when the test actually runs this
significantly reduced our Tusk test
runtimes by over 30% just imagine when
you run tests at 2.4 billion in
vacations reducing test times by 30%
would yield a huge number of like you'd
save huge amounts of CPU resources one
of the other features that we are going
to work probably next year is a cloud
snapshots which is combination of
texture on the cloud and snapshots call
it cloud snapshots but this we come to
our end of our talk where with nitrogen
you'd be able to run your tested scale
in a completely stable environment with
all of these different pillars this is
our next-generation platform that will
help you test in this talk we did do a
lot of technical stuff like deck stomp
f6
activity controller you don't have to
worry about any of those things because
all of these things are already
incorporated in nitrogen as well as the
virtual device management solution and
all you would have to do is like use
this so we are hoping to release
nitrogen alpha in q1 of next year the
virtual device management solution is
going to be released around the same
time as well with an alpha release
firebase test lab is actually
integrating with nitrogen as well to run
your tests one of the things that's
different pointed out earlier about
integration of my Android studio and
Gradle with nitrogen just imagine you're
sitting in front of your Android studio
you hit the run test button which
actually invokes nitrogen which could
actually launch the virtual device to
run your test and give you results back
on your Android studio itself and that's
farted thank you very much
[Applause]
that it alright well hey everyone I
wanted to thank you all for coming and
attending the Android dev summit it is
really really amazing to be able to do
this again we really want to know what
you think and this is really important
so all of you should by now or very soon
we'll get a survey in your inbox please
please please fill it out
because it is we so much wanted to make
this event amazing should we ever do it
again we really want to know what worked
and what didn't work what what you liked
what you didn't like less Dan Galpin
maybe you know second thing is we are
gonna we have these QR codes which we
might be able to put up one more time
hopefully and though these are how you
rate the sessions and so we want to know
what sessions you loved what sessions
you only liked what sessions you sat
through because they were there in the
same room and you we're kind of
comfortable in your seat so please also
fill out these surveys and let us know
it worked I know it's a lot of work but
I really appreciate that and ultimately
if you missed anything
all of these talks are actually up today
right now okay I guess that's gone all
the talks that we have are up on the
Android developers YouTube channel and
and so again I think and from yesterday
and most of them from today are already
going up and by I think the end of
tonight all of them will be up on the
channel so you'll be able to even go
home tonight if you haven't had enough
Android dev summit by now you can even
have more from the comfort of your very
own history museum and and finally we
have a little bit of a final reel here
of just some of what was going on here
that we'll have we should we'll share to
you as you think about wandering out
here and going back to the real world so
thank you so much for coming again
welcome to the 2018 Android developer
summits this is an event for developers
by developers
with over two billion devices three
quarters of a trillion apps downloaded
every year androids developer community
is growing hugely we saw it more than
double just in the past few years
[Music]
so the Android app bundle makes it much
simpler with no additional developer
work needed the app bundle now makes
apps an average of 8 percent smaller to
download for m+ devices we simply could
not do this thank you so thank you
[Music]